こんにちは!
はじめしゃちょーです。
みなさん
磁石好きかい?
そう!
僕も磁石で
重力を無視した部屋を作ろうと思ってるんで
床を全部Ｎ極にして
自分もＮ極でもう
反発しあって浮いちゃうみたいな
そういうね
無重力空間をちょっ作ろうと思ってるんで
まっ、今回はそれの試作ですよ
そういう強大な磁石の実験をしようと思ってるんで
そこでなんか
ちょっとなんか面白いもの見つけてきたんで
買ってしまいました
髪の毛入ってるよ!!
フゥ～!
なんかこういうの見つけました
これだけ見てもわかりづらいと思うんだけど
なんかね、磁石が入ってるんですよ
開けてみましょう!
おぉ!
小さいなぁ
これも全部ツブツブで
全部磁石なんですよ
あれ?なんか思ったより小さくね?
わ～、これさぁ俺さぁ、遊んでみたかったんですよね
わーわーわー、うわぁっ!
あぁ、わあぁ!
すごい!
さっきまで四角だったのに
もう今じゃ
こんな丸い子に
ほらほらほら
もうこんな、これよ
ほほほほっっ!
おぉ～っ!
おおっ!
は!
はぁああ!!
はああ!!
フゥッ、とぅおおおお!
はあああ!!
いや俺これねすっごい面白いと思ったんすよ!
で、10個買いました
これさぁ、すごいなんか無限のちっ、可能性を感じると思うんすよ
ベイマックス見た人ならわかると思うんですけども
あのベイマックスの主人公の
コウスケ
あいつはねぇ、天才だよ!
磁石みたいなんでね、なんかロボットを作ってねぇ
自由自在に、なんか体を変えれるみたいな
ま、僕もちょっとコウスケを見習ってね
この大量の細かい磁石を使ってなんか
いろいろできるんじゃねぇかと思いましてね
なんかやってみます
わあ
このりょ
あああああああああ!
こいつはすげぇぞ!
2160個の磁石ボールがあるんで
というわけで今日は
この・・・
大量の磁石を使って
どんなことができるのか
っていうのをちょっとね
いろいろ考えて皆さんに教えていれけれれれれ…
と思います
ではいきましょう!
ピアスいけそう
どう?　どう?
どう?
ああ
おあ、ピア、スだ
ちゃんとピアスになってるよ、ほら
ああぁ…
ええぇっ!?
あれっ?なくした!
え!?なくした、なくした
あった
鼻にすごい数の磁石が集まる事故になってもーぅ
この大き磁石さえあれば
簡単に取れます
両鼻とかでも大変ですね
もし何かの不慮の事故で
うう!
いった!!
もし何かの事故で
鼻の
両方の鼻の穴に磁石が詰まってしまった場合
普通に取れますね
wwww、っち
あ、いた!!
づうぅ!!
ふん゛ふん゛
へぇあ
へぇあ!
magnet!
まぁ、ちゃーしょう(多少)の量の磁石が鼻に詰まる事故が起きても
この強力な磁力で
なんかドラゴンとかでも作れないもんかねぇ
いけない気もしないなぁ
あー、微妙
でもぽいよねー
ほら!　ちょっと伝わります?
かろうじて恐竜だと思います
でもなんか作れるっちゃぁ、作れますね
恐竜とか
うん
俺も暇だな
冷蔵庫は鉄なんでたぶんくっつくんすよ
ほら!
おい!
ああ!
おぉぉぉおおおお!
特に面白くありません
ほんといろんな楽しみ方ができますね
では次いってみましょう
結構来ちゃってるよ、これぇ
こんなもんかな?
うえぇええい!
へえぇぇえ!
はい、っつわけでこんな感じでですねー
縄跳びも作れます
はいというわけでちょっと、縄跳びが完成したので実際に跳んでみましょう
しっかりくっついているとね、多分大丈夫だと思います
いきます
うあああああ!
うあああああああああああ(スロー)
みんな!!!
はい、というわけで皆さんいかがだったでしょうか
まあ、磁石がたくさんあってもね
思ったよりできることは少な…、あ!
思ったよりできることは少なかったです
磁石っていうのはやっぱね
力がなくても動くんで
やっぱ未来を感じますね
楽しんでぜひ皆さんもやってみてください
じゃあな!!
いっちゃあ!!!